[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
michigan state lost again to duke i
think that's the fifth time coach k has
defeated michigan state in the
tournament michigan state head coach tom
izzo joining us on the program were you
aware of that number coach that uh coach
k has uh
ousted you five times in the tournament
yeah i'm aware of all those numbers you
don't know any of the wins but you know
all the losses yeah
what could you have done differently
well the game plan was not to let them
get into the paint
um
and they drove us to death at the end i
thought we did a poor job of
tr of uh taking away the paint in the
last five minutes of the game and they
got in there and got fouled made some
tough layups other than that i thought
we played awfully well to be honest with
you they're very talented team good team
um we did a decent job we just couldn't
finish the job
conversation with coach k uh did you
talk pregame or just post game
you know we talk pregame for a minute
but nothing about anything that's uh
relevant and then a little bit after but
maybe a little more in the hallway after
the press conference you know and uh
i mean you got to respect what he's done
and i appreciate what he's done for
basketball and
definitely for duke but uh
during the game it was all about uh
wanting to win and both guys wanted to
win and he did
for the fifth time
as you as you remind me i know i i
should have i should have started with
something more like hey man well that
was a great coaching effort yesterday
and instead i'd lead with the negative
so my bad we're two and two in the last
four so you could have led with that but
i don't blame you i uh
i said that's uh
that's been a nemesis for me that i
haven't been able to take care of and
now i won't get that chance again
but when
does it enter your mind at all during
the game
that this could be coach k's last game
and you're going to take him out
i think more before the game than than
during during the game it's just you
know as they say once the ball is tossed
all those things are forgotten um
i thought about it in the last 20
seconds when we were down six and they
were shooting free throws but other than
that uh didn't think about it during the
game
you were pretty animated
like you were laughing i don't know if
you were laughing to avoid being angry
at the officiating but
the the camera caught you laughing a few
times your head was on the scorer's
table one time what what are you
thinking about there uh with the
officiating
oh god are you trying to get me fined
borrow money from you i don't think you
can get fined for this it was a pretty
well officiated game i i thought there
was one stretch
when there were three calls in a row in
the same possession
um that bothered me but other than that
uh
i don't care i got uh you know it was a
little bit of a home court advantage for
him you know playing right in their
backyard and
and uh
but uh
that's all i'll say about that well they
can't find you if you say something like
the officials were terrible in that game
uh they weren't terrible uh they're just
uh there were times uh inconsistent
yeah there was a little inconsistency uh
you know but um
i wouldn't say the officials cost us the
game
uh we didn't take care of business he
had a five point lead with under five
minutes
um but i i think we're where duke really
did a good job
and when they got beat by north carolina
at the end of that game
i thought they just settled for threes
and were firing the ball all over and in
our game they didn't at all
one kid hit a big three but other than
that um
they drove the ball got to the free
throw line and that's what you do uh-oh
that's the ncaa
now i got rid of them okay yeah you
don't need to hear from them that that
that might be a five thousand dollar
phone call
no right now i don't think the ncaa does
much you know
i think they're afraid i'll sue them
[Laughter]
yeah i don't think the ncaa does much of
anything when do you look at the game
film of the loss to duke
i did at uh 11 o'clock last night on the
way home i watched the whole game oh
but then i'll watch it today you know
and just so it's fresh in my mind and
then uh
then move on you know either try to
figure out who you're gonna recruit or
who's transferring or which portal
you're gonna go into or
who's gonna pay somebody or all the good
new rules that we have today that i
can't stand personally
but the game has changed so much i mean
you talked about some of these things
with the portals but but just the
philosophy that everybody thinks there's
steph curry how do you as a coach
encourage or discourage somebody from
taking those those threes
you know that is a fine line because i
think every kid now if you're seven foot
there's no such thing as being inside
everybody wants to be a shooter
um the problem is there's not many steph
curry's
and uh i like the way draymond does it
out there he knows he's not steph curry
so he just gets steph curry the shots
and yet trying to encourage somebody in
college to do that is
is a little uh more difficult
well it might be as hard to find a
draymond green as it is as steph curry
when you think about it
i think it's harder i i think that's a
great point you know even in your point
guards you know getting guys that make
other players better as magic would say
is harder everybody wants to make
themselves better so that's one of the
challenges we have and if you don't
score more points you don't get as much
nil money if you don't get more
uh rebounds you don't get as much nli
money so
um kids have different uh
reasons now to do things that make it a
little more difficult and why i think
you've seen some coaches stepping down
tom izzo 54 tournament wins eight final
four appearances ranks fifth all time
and uh winning percentage in the
tournament just over 70 percent as a
third behind coach k and john calipari
what do you do differently in the
tournament there's certain coaches we
talk about certainly you're one of those
where we go michigan state ncaa
tournament you know that iso is going to
do jay wright's another guy that comes
up and i know you have to have talent
but there's something
is there anything you're doing
differently as as opposed to the regular
season
you know dan i think you develop a
culture where kids start believing that
you know even though it's not true i
mean uh i said our fans think i golf
you know november december january and
then start working in february and then
you know do something in march that's
not true but
um
i think some of it's the culture the
former players you know everybody just
has this belief and uh
i got to get them to start believing
that in december that's my next goal so
this year i'm going to try to work the
whole six months
you're tied with coach k for the most
consecutive ncaa tournament appearances
at 24.
i'm i'm rooting for you to beat him next
year
yeah yeah me too um and maybe i can
since he will not be there yes
otherwise i think i'm three and
13. i mean you would probably have the
stat there because you're a stats guy
yeah you're you're three and 13 against
coach k all the time but i was not
bringing that up i gave you a positive i
told you about the eight final four
appearances
yeah that's not bad i mean we got that
in 27 years he's got 12 and 42 years so
i guess i'm still in range of that one
but uh he's earned everything he's
gotten you know and and yet i think
we've uh we've done some incredible
things here
with uh some to go dan we're gonna we're
not done yet
the is that green shag carpeting that
you have there
it's not shag i mean we're not in the
70s okay you were in college we're in uh
you know it's it's very cut pile okay is
it like aster turf
it should be you know i'm a football fan
so maybe that's a good thing maybe i'll
change the astroturf maybe we'll get a
little tougher are you uh are you a
lions fan
well i am because i'm in this state but
i grew up a packer fan i live 90 miles
from green bay and uh
everybody in the up where i'm from is
packers fan
did you ever uh
meet bart starr or brett favre
i did you know because of my buddy mary
you cheap art star came up to our golf
outing in the up a couple times he was
great
and brett favre came once or twice and i
got a chance to meet him too through
mariucci but
those guys were great haven't met aaron
rodgers yet but uh
maybe someday well he's there for maybe
another couple of years so maybe why
don't you go to a game
oh i've gone to uh a couple packer games
um yeah because you take september
october november and december off so you
could go uh to a lot of games there
coach
uh you're so right um
but i i do uh matt lafleur is a guy that
spent a lot of time in the state of
michigan his coach so
i do get over there in fact talk to matt
during the playoffs so i hopefully uh
i'll get over there one of his uh summer
workouts when does your voice
sound smooth you know it's been really
good this year but i didn't get much
sleep and to be on the dan patrick show
i said i don't care if i got up got to
bed at four in the morning i'm getting
up early who's got the worst coaching
voice
where's co bob huggins
bob's gotta have the worst voice
uh
or i tell bob he looks the worst
you don't wanna get him angry though
i love bobby's he's one of the good guys
in the profession doc rivers has a voice
that has never changed right that that's
a coach's voice
you know what doc does and uh doc's been
a good friend too i coached in the
goodwill games with him a few years ago
and uh
he does a great job and he's got a great
voice and he's always tired too because
i would like to do that for 90 games
no way
uh hey great to talk to you as always
thanks for uh getting up and joining us
and uh there's always next year right
thanks dan maybe uh we'll get together
with those dating flyers sometime yeah
yeah well dayton should have been in
i agree
yeah that was disappointing after you
know a year ago where they could have
won it all with uh obi topping and that
team they might have been as good as
anybody uh thank you coach great to talk
to you as always
thanks dan that's uh tom izzo